مجمل الانتاج من المصادر جميع يصل الى 11
مليون متر مكعب يوميا طبعا هذا الانتاج
الحضري هذا فقط لانتاج الحضري اللي يشمل
السكني والحكومي
وجزء من الصناعي
والتجاري في فجوه متوقعه باربعه ونص مليون
متر مكعب بحلول عام 2026 هذه فجوه مياه
متوقعه في السعوديه بناء على قياسكم الطلب
والعرض لو تحدثنا عن هذه الفجوه كيف كيف
نتعامل معها
[موسيقى]
هذا سقراط من اذاعه ثمانيه وانا عمر
الجريسي استضيف قاده التحول وقاده الاعمال
وقاده الراي وسولف معهم مع المستجدات
ومستدفات رؤيه السعوديه 2030 ضيف حلقه
اليوم هو المهندس خالد القريشي الرئيس
التنفيذي للشركه السعوديه لشركات المياه
موضوع المياه نعمه عظيمه اعتقد من كثر ما
الفناها نسينا قديش احنا يعني
معتمدين عليها بطريقه مختلفه في السعوديه
بحكم ندره الموارد المائيه او ندره
الانهار صار الاعتماد بشكل كبير على محطات
التحليه في هذه الحلقه تكلمنا عن الشركه
اللي تشتري المياه من محطات التحليه
وتبيعها على شركات توزيع المياه داخل
المدن
وايضا هذه الشركه هي اللي تطرح مناقصات
انشاء محطات التحليه من قبل قطاع الخاص
وشراء المياه واعاده بيعها على شركات
التوزيع وكذلك لها علاقه بموضوع معالجه
المياه ولها علاقه ايضا بالخزنه
الاستراتيجي للمياه في السعوديه في بدايه
الحلقه تكلمنا على اللاعبين في القطاع
بشكل عام بحكم القطاع المياه ما هو قريب
مننا مره كمنظومه فما نعرف كل واحد ايش
الدور حقه ففهمنا مين اللي ينتجون مين
اللي ينقلون مين اللي يوزعون المياه
فهمنا
التكلفه الاكبر جايه من وين وبعدين اخذنا
يعني تعمق في دور الشركه ونشاطهم مين
يملكهم كيف يحققون ربح هل هم اصلا شركه
ربحيه ولا لا وبعدين اخذنا مثال لعمليه
طرح مناقصات محطات التحليه كيف يتم تحديد
هذه المياه تروح لمن وين تبنى هذه المحطه
كيف يختار او يتم اختيار الفائز في انتاج
المياه
كيف قدرنا ننتج او قدرنا الحمد لله في
السعوديه نحقق اقل
تكلفه انتاج مياه محلاه على مستوى العالم
في محطه محدده ذكرها ضيفنا وبعد ذلك
انتقلنا لمجموعه من اسئلتكم الثمينه مثل
هل تحليه المياه تلوث البيئه البحريه او
تزيد الملوحه فيها وبالتالي تؤدي الى
خسائر في الثروه السمكيه البحريه هل في
خطر
على امننا المائي بما اننا معتمدين بنسبه
عاليه جدا على محطات التحليه هل في مشكله
في عام 2026 او فجوه في انتاج المياه وكيف
حيساعدون في حلها موضوع الخزنه
الاستراتيجي السعوديه تعتبر
اقل بكثير من المتوسط العالمي اللي يقول
انه الخزنه الاستراتيجي يكفيك سبع ايام في
السعوديه ما يكفي الا نص يوم فكيف سيتم
التعامل مع هذا التحدي الى اخر اسئلتكم
الثمينه اترككم مع الحوار حياك الله ابو
عبد الله شرفتونا ونورتنا الله يحييك شكرا
لك ابو عبد الفرق بين الرياض اللي غادرتها
وان طالب جامعي والرياضه اللي رجعت لها
وانت رئيس تنفيذي وبين الغيابين حدود 24
سنه
ولا فرق كبير لكن روح الرياض باقي يعني حب
الرياض حتى لو غادرت من رجعت كاني راجع
البيت لكن الرياض
كانوا اهل الشرقيه لجنه الاجازات اهل
الرياض يروحون الان العكس اصبحت الرياض
اكثر جاذبيه واكثر مدنيه
ممتعه الرياض الان وانت كنت ساكن في
الجبيل صح كنت ساكن في الجبيل في الجبيل
اول في سكانيا التحليه لمده 12 سنه وبعدين
في الجبيل الصناعيه في الهيئه الملكيه هم
دائما اذا بغوا كذا يعني
يجلدون الذات يقولون شوفوا الشوارع الجبيل
شوفوا خدمات الجبيل قارنوها بالرياض هذه
فرقت معك شلون واجد حتى عندي البنات الله
يحفظهم
[موسيقى]
في مكان مدينه مثلا صغيره وتقول تبغى تخلص
مثلا اكثر مشوار في يوم واحد لا ما
هي العالم يعني مش موجود في الرياض فانا
اقول اذا انت مخطط من بدري يعني حتى ايام
ما كنت انا في الجامعه الملك سعود اخذ 20
الى 25 دقيقه حتى اصل الجامعه انا كنت
ساكن برا
[موسيقى]
نورمال يعني مدينه المشوار الواحد
احنا سعداء ابو عبد الله نستضيفك اليوم
بصفتك رئيس التنفيذي للشركه الوطنيه
لشراكات المياه
او الشركه السعوديه الشركه السعوديه
لشراكات المياه وهي صراحه شركه جدا مثيره
لانه ما حد عارف او مو بحد بس كثير ما
يعرفونش بالضبط تسوي واحنا كان عندنا
حلقات سابقه مع قاده المنظومه المياه في
بنحطها في وصف الحلقه للي مهتمين يرجعون
تشوفونها بس قبل ما ندخل في نشاط الشركه
ودنا نعرف بشكل عام قطاع المياه في
السعوديه لو نعطي كذا لمحه على القطاع
مصادر المياه من اكثر المستهلكين للمياه
ايش الجهات اللي تعمل في المنظومه ودور كل
واحد منهم نفهم المشهد بشكل عام بعدين
ندخل مباشره على الشركه
اول شيء شاكر لك محاوله القاضه وعلى
الشركه
القطاع بالمجمل قطاع المياه
فيه حسب الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للمئه وفي
الانتاج اللي هو المصدر وفي النقل وفي
التوزيع فالانتاج في انتاج من محطات تحليه
تحليه المياه المالحه تعرف حنا في المملكه
ما فيه ما في مصادر
جاريه زي الانهار
لكن في مصادر جوفيه
ففي مصادر من انتاج مياه الماء من التحليه
وفيه من المصادر الجوفيه اللي السطحيه او
الغير متجدده
وفيه نقل او في توزيع فالمصادر عموما هي
تقريبا 70% من انتاج مياه التحليه اللي هي
مياه صالحه للشرب من محطات تحليه اللي على
الساحلين الشرقيه نعم وفي عندنا مياه
الابرار اللي هي الجوفيه اللي هي تقريبا
تعتبر في الغالب غير متجدده وفي المياه
السطحيه اللي هي من السدود من السدود نعم
المؤسسات او الشركات اللي تقوم بها الدور
على راسهم المؤسسه العاملي تحت المياه
طبعا هي اللي عندها الدور الاكبر والاقدم
بصراحه في القطاع او الحقيقه يعني عندها
مجموعه من محطات تصل فوق الثلاثين محطه
وجهدهم الحقيقه جبار ومقدر ثم كان النقل
كذلك يتم عن طريق المؤسسه الان انشات شركه
جديده اسمها شركه نقل وتقنيات المياه
دورها الاساسي نقل المياه وايضا تطوير في
الطفل في التقنيه ثم التوزيع يجي عند شركه
المياه الوطنيه احنا في الشركه في القطاع
كدور دورنا بدانا عضيد
انتاج او انشاء محطات لتحليه المياه بس عن
طريق الشراكه مع القطاع الخاص فبدات هذه
من عام 2003 عندما انشات الشركه كان اسمها
طبعا السابق شركه الماء والكهرباء حيث
تمشي محطات انتاج مياه بس انها انتاج
المياه في ذلك الوقت لم يكن الا بطريقه
الانتاج المزدوج يعني لابد يكون عندك
كهرباء وما بنفس الوقت لانها انتاج محطات
عن طريق التقنيه الحراريه
فكانت الشركه مملوكه
للتحليه بخمسين بالمئه بعد قرار مجلس
الاقتصادي لاعلى لانشائها وخمسين بالمئه
للمؤسسه العامه طبعا انشئ في ذلك الوقت
ثلاث محطات او ثلاثه العامه المؤسسه
العامه تحت المياه 50% وشركه الكهرباء 50%
هذا اجابه على القطاع بالمجمل كل دور
للقطاع وبدلنا نتكلم في القطاع كم
انتاجنا وكم استهلاكنا اليوم في السعوديه
المجمل الانتاج من المصادر جميع يصل الى
11 مليون متر مكعب يوميا
واهم المستهلكين حسب ما فهمت قطاع الزراعي
طبعا هذا الانتاج الحضري هذا فقط للانتاج
الحضري اللي يشمل السكني والحكومي
وجزء من الصناعي
والتجاري هذول يستهلكون 11 مليون الزراعي
الحاله الظاهر يستهلك 14 ولا كم يستهلك في
اليوم
مستقل ما يحضر من الرقم الزراعي لكن
الزراعي من الاستهلاك السنوي للمياه
بالمجمل للمياه هو الاغلب 84% نعم يصل الى
85%
مليون هذه فقط
الحضري
والاستهلاك الزراعي ما يدخل ضمن
مصادر هذا الانتاج وانما يعتمد على المياه
الجبار
وهذه يمكن يصرفنا فيها وغطيناها اكثر في
حلقه مؤسسه الري بس لما نتكلم اليوم على
الشركه
وش الغرض من تاسيسها ليش ما كانت المؤسسه
العمل التحليه هي اللي تطرح هذه الشركات
مع قطاع الخاص
طبعا النموذج كان يحتاج
رشد في القطاع بالكامل حتى انت تجيب
المستثمر ويكون قبيله واحد من الدوله
مضمون من الدوله
عشان يبدا يضع راس مال وينشئ المحطه ويبيع
عليك ويبيع عليك وياخذ العائد له الاصول
اللي انشاها خلال فتره اتفاقيه او
الامتياز طبعا الامتياز سواء عشرين سنه او
25 سنه فيحتاج الى قبيل واحد يسمى
فانشى هذه الاوف تيكر جميع النماذج اللي
العربي متعهد الشراء متعهد الشراء اوضاع
من الشراء ضامن الشراء وهذا الضمان هو نقل
مخاطر للاصول المبنيه من القطاع الخاص
تضمنها الدوله عن طريق هذا الكيان اللي
تنشا الدوله وتضمنه ضمان مالي
هذا السبب فالمؤسسه كانت هنا منتج وتبني
اصول بس عن طريق التمويل الحكومي ميزانيه
والحكومه تجيها عثمان وتبني وهي تاثير
تتملك هذه الاصول
وتصينا وتشغلها
طوال فتره عمر
المحطه وعلى حسب فهمي الانتاج اللي هي
بشكل رئيسي المؤسسه العامه للتحليه هذه
تبني المحطات وتنتج مياه محلات صحيح شركه
نقل وتقنيات المياه هذه مسؤوله عن شبكه
النقل اللي هي من منطقه الانتاج الى
بوابات المدن احسنت بعدين شركه الوطنيه
للمياه اللي هي مسؤوله توزيع هذه اللي
تبني الشبكه داخل المدينه وتوزع وتشمل
الصرف الصحي صحيح انتم وين دوركم في هذه
الحلقه بعد ما احنا نجي طبعا الان بعد
تطور المنظومه ونقل
يكون الشراء ليس فقط عن طريقنا من القطاع
الخاص وانما ايضا مع قطاع العام
اصبح عندنا اتفاقيات لكل الشراء سواء قطاع
عام اللي هو محطات تحت القائمه او قطاع
خاص اللي تبنى عن طريق القطاع الخاص ثم
يتم اتفاقيه اخرى اسمها اتفاقيه البيع
المستمر مع التوزيع
فانت تشتري من المنتجين وابيع على التوزيع
وبنفس الوقت ارتفع قيمه خدمه النقل لشركه
النقل ايضا باتفاقيات تجاريه
بعد التوزيع يتم تجميع المياه من البيوت
ويتم معالجتها عن طريق محطات معالجه صرف
صحي وايضا احنا نقوم بتطويرها وبنائها مع
القطاع الخاص كذلك فحتى موضوع معالجه
المياه وبعد المعالجه
يكون من ضمن البناء الان حديثا يعني تم
وضع انابيب تصل الى عشرين خمسه وعشرين
يبنيها القطاع الخاص للمساهمه في
الاستفاده من المياه المجدده في الزراعه
او في الصناعه وهذه تبيعها انت على
الاعلانات مؤسسه الريان على مؤسسه الريان
سلمنا مؤسسه الريكا مسؤول عن التعامل مع
المياه المجدده في كل المملكه العربيه في
كل المناطق المملكه العربيه السعوديه جميل
هذول اللاعبين كلهم فوقهم منظم صحيح اللي
هم منظم المياه او وكاله
شلون التنظيميه في الوزاره صحيح وش دورها
وش علاقتكم فيها
طبعا هو
عنده كل تنظيمات المياه وايضا يصدر الرخص
رخص البناء رخص التشغيل
المتابعه على جوده المنتجات جوده جوده
المياه المنتجه له ايضا دور في التاكد من
مطابقتها ليست يوميا وانما كل فتره
هو منظم ضروري واخذ منه التصاريح لمنشاه
هذه المحطات بس عاده في اغلب القطاعات
المنظم يكون هيئه في حالتكم انتم منظمكم
وكاله غريبه وش السبب لا هو هو في الاساس
لدينا
منظم الماء والكهرباء المزدوج اللي هو
ويرا او اكرار سابقا لكن حديث صار في قرار
مجلس الوزراء حتى يتمكن القطاع من
المضي للامام فتره مؤقته صار المنظم
الوكاله في الوكاله لكن الاصل انه الهيئه
الهيئه نفسنا
وهذا لا طبعا هذا قرار صدر يعني من سنه
ونص واصبحت من ضمن الوزاره عالميا هل هذا
هو النموذج الموجود انه يكون فيه
وسيط شراء وبيع في النص بين المنتج وبين
الموزع
احنا خاصه فيها دعم لا لا هو لما تصبح
الامور اكثر
رشت ونضج في القطاع
ومحاكمة تجاريه يصبح الاوفتيكر او متعهد
الشراء ما هو موجود وممكن ينتقل هذا الدور
الى جهات اخرى
ننتقل مباشره الى الى الى التوزيع مثلا
على سبيل المثال يعني يصير هو التوزيع هو
اللي يشتري مباشره بس هذه تحتاج لها ضبط
بحيث انه السوق
يطمئنوا فيها الاليات والاجهزه الكامله
سواء تجاريا
اتفاقيه التجاريه او حسابيه يعني عدادات
حتى يضمن الشراء الى الحين هذا الوقت
وتصبح يعني يصبح الامر امر تجاري بين منتج
وعنده
مصادر وعنده كميات واين موزع يبغى هذا
الانتاج ويبدا ياخذ حتى الاقل سعرا يمكن
ما تحتاج لكن في الخليج العربي عموما هذا
ايضا في العالم العربي تقريبا موجود هذا
النموذج والغريب انه انتم شركه ولكن على
عكس اغلب الشركات الحكوميه اللي يملككم ما
هو بصندوق الاسطولات العامه اللي تملككم
وزاره الماليه وش السبب هل انتم شركه
ربحيه هل تربحون ولا ما تربحون لا ما نربح
احنا الان دورنا فقط وسيط اللهم ناخذ
تكاليفنا من
تكاليف الاداره التشغيليه من البيع فقط
لكن ليس لنا ربح ولا عايد على ربح وليس
يعني
محدد لنا الى الان السبب انه كان صندوق
الاستثمارات المشاريع الاولى اللي على
بدايات الشركه كان شريك
يعني كان القطاع الخاص ما يدخل بكامل
الميه بالميه من حصه انشاء المحطه او محطه
انتاج التحليه وانما يدخل ب 60% والاربعين
بالمئه الدوله 32% صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه
والثمانيه المتبقيه شركه الكهرباء
فكوني يصير هو مالك لهذه يصير فيه نوع من
يعني
لوزاره الماليه وزاره الماليه اليوم
المياه في السعوديه دائما نسمع انها سلعه
مدعومه وانها تباع باقل من التكلفه فكيف
تديرون انتم فرق يعني انت قاعد تشتري من
التحليه بسعر وتبيع للموزع باقل من سعر
الشراء ولا لا
انا اشرح لك الان اخوي بالنسبه للقطاع
الخاص انت
لما تطرح المشروع
وتطرح المشروع انه اقل واحد في التعرفه او
في التكلفه هو اللي يفوز
بشرط انه يكون
المواصفات الفنيه الموجوده في العرض تمام
فانت تدفع له كامل تكلفته بالكامل لما
تيجي تنقل هذه الى التوزيع
تبيعه بنفس السعر الان اللي مدعوم وين
اللي هو يروح للمواطن لان انت في خليط من
فيه انتاج وفي نقل وفي توزيع تكلفه
الانتاج مقارنه بالدوره كامله دوره الماء
من المصدر الى انت اصل ليس الاعلى في
الانتاج الاعلى فيها في في النقل ثم
الانتاج ثم التوزيع عجيب النقل مكلف جدا
لانك تتكلم على مملكه قاره تتكلم على
مسافات كبيره جدا يعني من الجبيل الى
الرياض وفي ارتفاعات ايضا من الساحل
الغربي مثلا مناطق سي عسير وكذا مرتفع جدا
تحتاج طاقه تحتاج راس مال مكلف
[موسيقى]
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
هل ممكن ناخذ ابو عبد الله مثال لحاله
محدده
وناخذ منها القصه من اولها لاخرها عشان
نفهم دوركم حاله من بدايه طرح الفرصه ليش
حددته هذه الفرصه ليش اخترتوا هذه المنطقه
ليش حددته هذه الساعه مين اللي فاز فيها
شلون فاز بكم سعر الشراء
على منبعته والى اخر القصه لو ناخذ مثال
واحد من اوله لاخره هل ممكن ممكن مثلا
نختار
اقل مشروع تعرفه في العالم الان اللي هو
مشروع
جزله والجبيل ثلاثه الف في منطقه الجبيل
على الساحل الشرقي
مشروع سعه 600 الف متر مكعب في اليوم
المستهدف فيه منطقه الرياض منطقه القصيم
هذا المشروع طبعا حدد الحاجه
بناء على العرض والطلب
العرض الطلب يقول في فرق في الحاجه وتحتاج
تنشئ محطه او مصدر المياه
الخيارات امامك يا اما انك انت تحفر في
الابار الغير متجدده وتنتج وتعالج التنقيه
او تاخذ من البحر وتنقل عنب
هذا يتم عن طريق
لجنه العرض والطلب اللي هي تراسها وزاره
البيئه والمياه والزراعه وفيها اعضاء لم
شركاء تحت المياه من شركه المياه الوطنيه
واحنا والمنظم
حدد المكان
في منطقه الجبيل
لتوافر خطوط النقل المطلوب لنقل المياه
الى المنطقه المطلوب دعمها في المياه لانه
في شبكه حاليا قصدي الشبكه وفيه
وفيه خطوط ناقله فانت بتعتمد على نفس
الخطوط اللي موجوده اليوم ما حتبني خط
جديد لا في خطوط ناقله تتسع الى جزء وفي
ايضا مرصود اموال لتوسعه تقوم فيها
المؤسسه العامه تحت المياه طرحت ايضا في
في نفس الفتره
والتوزيع ايضا لان انت تاخذ في منطقه
الرياض على سبيل المثال تاخذ جزء من محطات
التحليه والجزء الاخر تاخذه من الابار
المحيطه في الرياض اللي هي ابار الوسيع
تاخذ كميات من المياه فهذه تكون بديل ومع
النمو السكاني يظل تحتاج انتاج 100
فحدد المكان طبعا المكان عشان تحدد في
المكان المناسب لابد يكون في دراسه بيئيه
عمق البحر
دخول الانابيب الى داخل البحر حتى تطمن
انه الوضع
مناسب لان انت تاخذ بالبحر وترد البحر ولا
بتضمن ايضا تدوير المياه يتم بحيث ما
ترتفع نسبه الملوحه وتاثر على الانتاج
طبعا الموافقه على طرح المشروع مجلس
الوزراء ثم طرح المشروع
للقطاع الخاص طبعا احنا لما نجي نطرح
المشروع نضع
نطاق العمل يقوم فيه معانا مستشارين
مؤهلين سواء مالي او فني او قانوني ثم
نطرح المشروع للقطعه الخاص طبعا قبل لا
يطرح المشروع نرسل الى السوق نقول له منو
اللي راغب في الدخول في المشروع فنسويها
هذه ابدال رغبات مرحله ابدال رغبات
عاده يجينا خمسين الى خمسين راغب في
الدخول في المشروع
بعد ابدال الرغبات يتم
[موسيقى]
تاهيلهم
ومن هو اللي قادر على انه ينفذ في شروط
نضعها شروط ماليه وشروط فنيه يعني يكون
عنده سابق تجربه في عمل مثل هذه المشاريع
يكون عنده ملعقه ماليه وقدره على اقناع
الممولين على الدخول في المشروع
بعدين اطرح الكراسه الطلب العروض في
الجبيل اللي هو ثلاثه الف جزاء جاءنا
تقريبا حدود خمسه عروض
من تحالفات فيها ناس من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وفيها ناس من خارج المملكه
العربيه السعوديه يعني من فرنسا من
اسبانيا من
اليابان كان اقل
عرض اللي هو عرض اكوا باور
مع شريك شريكم البواني وفازوا فيه
سعر المتر المكعب ريال واربعين هلله
للمتر المكعب تقريبا 41 سنت كامل سواء
تمويل وانشاء
وتشغيله صيانه ولانه احنا مو بمختصين فما
نقدر نفهم هالرقم الي مدى كويس ولا لا كيف
تقارنوا بالارقام الاخرى هذا يعتبر اليوم
على نطاق العمل موجود اقل سعر لانتاج
تحليه من المياه مالحه بهذا بهذا بهذا
النموذج اقل سعر في العالم يعتبر يعني
الان اغلب العالم يحلون اغلب العالم
يعني الحاجه لتحليه المياه اصبحت معي حتى
في الدول اللي عندها انهار يعني اليوم
مثلا في مصر على سبيل المثال في فرنسا في
اسبانيا في في محطات تحليه
فهذا الرقم يعتبر الاقل الاقل ايضا الطاقه
عشان نكمل الفكره نفهمها فانت انت تقول
اليوم انه اكوا باور فازت لانها تقول
مستعده اشتري ابيع لكم المياه بهذا السعر
طوال مده الاتفاقيه اللي هي 25 والعشرين
صحيح هذا طبعا يسمى عشان بس نكون اوضح مع
هذا يسمى
اللي هو التعربه المعدل يعني بدايه
السنوات الاولى من من المشروع يكون اعلى
اقل اقل اقل لان في حسبه على
التضخم وتوقع
فاقل
فالمتوسط طول فتره الخمسه وعشرين سنه اللي
هو
الامتياز او الاتفاقيه الشراء بينه وبينهم
المتوسط ريال واربعين
احنا خلصنا الان بدا المشروع طبعا المشروع
كان لها ايضا بعض المميزات الجديده اول
شيء سمحنا لانشاء طاقه شمسيه حتى نخفض
تكلفه المتر المكعب فانشاه تقريبا ما
يعادل 30% من الحاجه للطاقه الكهربائيه في
المحطه من الطاقه الشمسيه تقريبا هناك
يمكن لما تروح ان شاء الله الجبيل
او تمرنا وننزل حنا ان شاء الله يوم من
الايام شيئا جزله يبين
مزرعه السولار النرجسي او الطاقه الشمسيه
كيف هي مميزه وكيف هي اضافت 30% من
الاحتياج هذا المحطه من الكهرباء من
الطاقه الشمسيه من الطاقه الشمسيه
والفائده منها انك انت بدل ما تشتري من
الشبكه ب 18 هلله تقريبا تشريه هنا اقل من
عشره هلالات فبالنهار توفر حدود ثمان
هلالات لكل متر مكعب تنتشر
الاخير
التكلفه الاساسيه للمشروع تنخفض وبنفس
الوقت انت خفضت ايضا الانبعاثات الكربونيه
وهكذا
المشروع الحمد لله الان هو تحت التشغيل
التجريبي
600 الف متر مكعب في ضخ في
في خزانات الجبيل وش تعتبر هذيك حجم 6 متر
الف هل هي من اكبر المحطات من اصغر المحبه
يعتبر احنا يمكن في المملكه بدانا في اكبر
انشاء اكبر محطات على التقنيه 600 الف
كانت بالنسبه للاخرين شيء
مستغرب خصوصا من 2018 الان لا يعني اليوم
المؤسسه العامه عندها ايضا مشروع بالمليون
متر مكعب
يعتبر من اكبر المشاعر الكبيره والمشروع
مشروع مشابه له رابط ثلاثه والان شغال
وسنتين الحمد لله هذا فاز في جائزه
جنس اللي اكبر مشروع تحليه تناضح عكسي
في العالم كم سعته 600 الف كذلك لكن ما في
طاقه شمسيه احنا وهذه ميزه احنا دائما
نحاول نعمل تطوير من مشروع الاخر يعني
رابط ثلاثه ما اضفناه الطاقه الشمسيه الان
اضفناه كنا حاطين 25% كاكاب لانه كم تحط
طاقه شمسيه مقارنه بالتوتال الان فتحنا
السقف سمحناه للمطورنا يعمل وهذا جاي لان
انت كل ما يكون عندك طاقات مصادر عاليه
تقدر تسمح في الرسك في المخاطر لكن في
البدايات لابغى تضمن انه كل هالكميه تصل
في
في وقتها عشان تصل للمواطنين واليوم كم
عدد المحطات الموجوده في السعوديه محطات
التحليه جمال
التحليه تصل الان
يمكن
36/73 الى حسبناها للمؤسسه للمؤسسه حدود
الثلاثين
اي اغلب المؤسسه وشدتها فقط قطع خاص
سته تقريبا قطاع خاص اضيف لها طبعا في
مشروع ايضا سته الى سبعه يعني عندنا اربع
مشاريع في سته مشاريع طبعا هذه اللي تشتغل
الان لكن اللي تم التعاقد معه اكثر من كذا
اللي لا تنشا بس ابو عبد الله ليش العدد
قليل في ظل ان احنا
الظاهر اول محطه طرحت في ثلاثه اللي فازت
فيها كانت ولادته اكو باور
بدانا ثلاث محطات ووقفنا
لكن في 2008 كان في تغير في قيمه التمويل
وكان الاجدى انك تبني عن طريق القطاع
العام يعني تاخذ من الميزان وتبني ثم لما
وصلنا الى الرؤيه وتوجيهات الرؤيه انه
يكون في مشاركات التنميه صار من اجل لك
انك ايضا تنوع من يكون معك في تنميه في
البنى التحتيه مع القطاع الخاص واليوم
وايضا تشترون من محطات التحليل الان صح
انتم
للكل كم فرق السعر بين القطاع العام وقطاع
الخاص شوف الان ما تقدر القطع الخاص هو
الاكثر كفاءه والاوسط بس انت ما تقدر يعني
زي ما يقولوا ما هي ما هي ما هي مقارنه ما
هي دقيقه لان في بعض المحطات في التحليه
اليوم بنيت زمان يعني
والتقنيه مختلفه نقول اجدد محطه للتحليه
مع محطه اكوا بارك كم الفرق ما عندي الرقم
طبعا هذه راح تبان في المستقبل بعد ما
تنقل بعض الاصول وتصبح في اتفاقيات شراء
ويبين كمل كابيتال اللي ضخ في هذه من قبل
وزاره الماليه او او ممول ويقوم المنظم
بمعايره ايهما اجدى بس لكن اليوم احنا ما
نتجه الى القطاع الخاص الا بعد القيمه
المضافه الماليه من انشاء عن طريق افضل من
القيمه الماليه المضافه من القطاع العام
واضح اخوي واضح يعني
هذا انت اليوم ما تاخذ موافقه من
هيئه كفاءه الانفاق بالموضي الى الامام
ارخص من القطاع الخاص افضل على المدى
الخمسه وعشرين طبعا في فرق بين الاثنين
واحد تحط الكابيتال في المقدمه في البدايه
انت فتاخذ راس مال من الدوله اما هذا لا
هذا يبني لك راس ماله ويقصد عليك انه يقصد
عليك بعدين تنتقل من الكيتو لك تنتقل طبعا
مو كلهم طبعا المحطات التحليه ما تنتقل
الملكيه
تنتهي مع انتهاء العقد محطات المعالجه
خطوط بخط التحليه ما تنتقل لكم لا تبقى
الملكيه صاحبها تنتهي يسمونه
بناء تشغيل تملك
النموذج مشوه جدا
فافرز نتيجه ما هي ما هي بالضروره
مرضيه من وجهه نظره اليوم وش اللي يعتبر
مخصص وايش اللي لا يزال غير مخصص في
منظومه المياه
الان اغلب الاغلب المنظومه فيها تخصيص
يعني لما تاخذ الانتاج
90% من الانتاج الان مخصص كيف يعني عندك
انت الان المؤسسه طلع القرار انه تنتقل
الوصول الى الى حلول المياه شركه تقنيات
وحلول المياه اللي انشات حديثا على شركه
جديده اي شركه جديده
تنتقل لها الاصول وهي بتصير الان تعتبر
منتج المياه بتصير بتصير هي من اهل الاصول
طبعا اختيارها الاصول هذا عندهم اكيد
معايير معينه لكن راح تبيع علينا احنا
كمشتري رئيس
ومحطات الانتاج اللي نسويها عن طريق
القطاع الخاص هاي طبعا تخصيص واضح وناجح
على فكره يعني الان تيجي للنقل اليوم
النقل اللي تكون فيه شركه
نقل وحلول مياه في الغالب وعندنا ايضا
مشاريع ايضا طارحين الام في السوق وهي
تعتبر اول مشاريع نقل مياه يتم محاوله
تخصيصها عن طريق القطاع الخاص واحنا على
صدرنا نستلم بعض العروض خلال شهر او شهرين
من الان فهذه بتثبت ايضا انه النقل كذلك
ممكن يتم
التوزيع لا بدات التوزيع وبدا الان عندك
اتفاقيات
طويله الامد في التشغيل في اكثر منطقه
وايضا بدات نسميها اللي هي اتفاقيات
الاداريه في في اكثر المنطقه ففي لكن
تحتاج لها وقت يعني وانت في الاخير قاعد
تلامس شيء مهم يعني كانت تتكلم عن المويه
يتكلم على شيء الناس كلها تحتاجه فاي خلل
فيه يسبب رده فعل رده الفعل احيانا يصير
لها يعني تخلي الامور ما تكون بالسرعه
تحتاج لها نوع من التروي والحكمه لكن انا
اعتقد ان القطاع ماشي في الاتجاه السليم
وهل يمكن تخصيص القطاع في ظل وجود دعم
بالسلعه يعني السلعه هذه مدعومه
الدعم ما له علاقه بالتخسيس انت بالاخير
المستثمر اللي بياخذها محلي او اجنبي يبغى
قيمه التكاليف اللي لا يبغى جزء من الربح
الان اذا انت بتدعم في جزء معين سواء في
الوقود او سواء في طاقه او سواء في البيع
فانت بالاخير هذه الدلتا راح تدفعها
الدوله اي في الفرق هذا
اليوم الفرق هذا وين قاعد يدفع هل هو يدفع
من خلال من خلالكم ولا من خلال الشركه
الوطنيه للمياه لا في في نموذج عمل او
يسمى صندوق الموازنه اللي طلع مع قرار
توسيع نطاق الشركه طلع في ايضا عمل صندوق
الموازنه اللي هو
الفرق بين التكاليف
وبين المبيوع
للمستخدم هذا يدفع تدفعه وزاره الماليه
الى هذا الصندوق هذا الصندوق الان تحت
اداره وزاره البيئه والمئه والزراعه
وهذه يدفع لمن يدفع للجهات يعني مثلا
المؤسسه اذا عندها فيها دلتا
يدفع الحجز معين الوطنيه كذلك احنا كذلك
ومع الوقت انت عندك قراءات تشوف وين
نقص الكفاءه وين موجوده فيه قاعد تطورها
مع الوقت يعني مثلا على سبيلنا وين وين
الفقت فيه في الانابيب في الشبكات تشتغل
عليها تقلل هذا الفقد حتى ترفع من قيمه
الماء المستخدم وتقلل التكلفه واليوم حسب
ما فهمت منك قبل شويه انه
اعلى كل فجايه من التوزيع من مش من
التوزيع من النقل او من النقل مال الحلو
هي النقل النقل المطلب جدا
لا خطوط النقل خطوط النقل
وحطينا على كل بناء اوكي وبعدها وبعدها
اذا ما نبغى الانتاج
واضح دائما في كلام مع التوزيع يجيك
وبعدين يجيك ايضا بعد التوزيع
المعالجه مادام طالب وعبد الله موضوع
المياه المعالجه وبدي اعرف احنا كم نعالج
من المياه اللي نستهلكها وكم نستفيد من
هذه المياه المعالجه
احنا تقريبا الانتاج من
المحطات يعني يصل الى
من ثمانيه الى عشره محطات التحليه
ومن الابار عشره مليون متر مكعب اللي
يعالج حدود الخمسه خمسه مليون متر مكعب في
نصف استهلاك تقريبا
اللي استفاد من المعالج المجدد حدود
العشرين بالمئه ليش يعني حرام صحيح هو هذا
هاجس عند
عند الوزاره وعند القطاع بالكامل
الاعاقه انه وين تستخدم
هل مع المجدد والجهه اللي تستفيد منها
والبنى التحتيه اللي توصلك الى الى
المستفيد فهي اداره هل المنظومه سواء طلب
وايضا لا يوجد ان يعني ان البديل ممنوع
يعني ما يكون في بديل اخر على سبيل المثال
لعمل معين المفترض انه يمنع حتى تستفيد من
المياه المجدده
هذه متاحه والناس ما تبيها مش متاح
بالكامل فيها متاح وفيها غير متاح لي مثلا
في اماكن بعيده من الزراعه احتاج الى
توصيل يحتاج له انابيب مد انابيب المحطات
تكون على اطراف المدن لكن اذا المزارع
مثلا بعيده او المصانع بعيده يحتاج الى مد
انابيب فهذه من الاساس تكون من ضمن
التشريعات اللي
تمنع استخدام مياه اخرى
حلوه او مياه ابار نظيفه
ويلزم باستخدام المياه المجدده فانا اعتقد
المنظومه او رفع نسبه
الاستفاده من المجدده يحتاج له
بنى تحتيه وبنفس الوقت تخطيط وهذا اللي
قال لليوم الوزاره تقوم عليه وايضا لا
مؤسسه الري شغالين على
هالخلط الشامله للاستفاده من المياه احنا
في الشركه
نحاول نمكن قدر المستطاع في النموذج اللي
بنيه مع القطاع الخاص بحيث انه نمد الخطوط
الى ما يقارب 30 كيلو متر حتى يستفاد منها
في مناطق القريبه من المدن الزراعه
او مصانع والى مثال مدينه الرياض اللي هي
تعتبر اكبر مدينه يمكن تستهلك مياه واكبر
مدينه فيها مياه معالجه صحيح
المياه المعالجه هذه وين يستفاد منها
يعني انت عندك خرج مشهوره بالمزارع مثلا
ولا ولا شمال الرياض ولا جنوب الرياض هذه
المياه هل هي الصالحه للاستخدام
الاصل انه صالحه للاستخدام لانه
معالجه ثلاثيه
ما تشترى الغالب المياه هذه تذهب مع
الوادي ويستفاد منها في في الوادي في
نهايه الوادي لكن
كتنظيم تجاري وكميات هي طبعا ليست من من
من مسؤوليات الشركه
عند مؤسسه الري
في خطط على الان يعملون عليها مؤسسه الري
حتى يتم الاستفاده من من هالمياه لكن هي
لا شك انها
منطقه تحتاج لها تطوير
وهي يعني محل اهتمام الجميع
[موسيقى]
وقريت تقريركم عن السبع سنوات الجايه او
السبع سنوات من عشرين عشرين الى 26 ولقيت
انه في فجوه متوقعه باربعه ونص مليون متر
مكعب بحلول عام 2026 هذه فجوه مياه متوقعه
في السعوديه بناء على قياسكم الطلب والعرض
لو تحدثنا عن هذه الفجوه كيف كيف نتعامل
معها
والله ابشرك الان احنا اللي اللي الان
طرحناه من المشاريع تغطي هذه الفجوه
يقارب ثلاثه فاصله
اثنين مليون متر مكعب هذا طرحت طرحت
واثنين منهم اشتغلوا مليون وخمسين رابط
ثلاثه لمنطقه مكه المكرمه 600 متر مكعب
وشقيق ثلاثه 450 الف متر مكعب والان محطه
جزله اللي هي في الجبيل ثلاثه الف الان
تحت التشغيل التجريبي وصلت الى 600 الف
المتبقي كله تحت الانشاء ينبع اربعه في
شاطئ الرايس في مرحله متقدمه 70% من
الانشاء 450 الف تقضي منطقه المدينه ان
شاء الله
ومستقبلا ايضا مناوره من مكه
والجبيل ثلاثه باء اللي هي الان 570 في
مرحله تقريبا 55% من الانشاء
كل هذه
مع
ان شاء الله راح تغطي الان حنا طارحين
ايضا رابط اربعه 600 الف ننتظر
توقيع اتفاقات التجاريه ان شاء الله خلال
الاشهر القريبه القادمه ان شاء الله مليون
اي نعم ان شاء الله
ومتبقي
مطروح الان وان شاء الله ما يجي ان شاء
الله سته وعشرين لحن مغطين باذن الله
ايضا في نفس التقرير قريت معلومه انه
تستهدفون بحلول عام 2025 ان يكون 90% من
مياه المدن محلات
صحيح واستثنيت اربع مناطق نجران وحايل
والجوف والحدود الشماليه وهذه دائما
تستثنونها في موضوع خدمات المياه المياه
المعالجه في عده نواحي وشركه في الاربع
مناطق هذه المياه
طبعا هذا
[موسيقى]
مياه الحلوه
او المحلاه في منطقه الشماليه
فيه مياه جوفيه
كافيه
لامداد المنطقه المنطقه الشماليه ومياه
يعني جيده للشرب وافضل يمكن من المياه
البحر فهذه الجوف
وحايل
نجران نجران غير مستثنى لا مش مستثناه
من من لها فيها لها محطات معالجه مرصوده
الان وموافق عليه وراح تبنى غير مستثمر في
التقرير انها من المناطق اللي
بيتم اعتماد على المياه الجوفيه اي طبعا
اذا كان هناك مياه جوفيه
قريبه زي ما او كميات
فالجدوه انك تنشي محطه وترسل لها
بالانابيب وقد يكون اولى انك تستخدم
المياه الجوفيه طبعا هذا هو النادر من من
في الحالات لكن الغالب انه استهداف اغلى
كل المدن في مئه
تحليه
والمياه الجوفيه تكون في حالات ضروره
والطوارئ
هنا في الدكتور عبد الله المستند في لقاء
سابق يقول الوضع مقلق بنظري في المملكه
اعتمدت على البحر الاحمر والخليج العربي
باكثر من 30 محطه هي الاكبر في العالم
والمملكه هي اول دوله في انتاج المياه
المحلاه وبالتالي 70% من سكانها يشربوه من
البحر وهنا تكمن الخطوره ان نشرب عبر الات
معرضه للمخاطر الطبيعيه او الامنيه يعني
دائما احنا نشوف هذا الشيء ميزه هو الان
بالعكس قاعد ينبهنا يقول انه ترى خطر فانت
وش رايك طبعا
[موسيقى]
اي فرصه هي من جهه ثانيه خطر الخطر احنا
في المملكه حولناه الى
فرصه بالاستفاده من تقنيه
الان عمليه
دار المخاطر هذه لها اليات والوزاره
والدوله تعمل عليه يعني
وجود مصدر مستمر من تحليه المياه وتقنيات
الان اصبحت رخيصه نسبيا مقارنه في السابع
وتحافظ على المياه الجوفيه الغير متجدده
انا اعتمدها شوف هذا انه من الابداع وانت
قللت بالعكس قللت المخاطر انت تحتاج تنمو
وتزدهر ولذلك تحتاج مصادر ميه فالاستفاده
من هذه التقنيه انا اعتقد انه فرصه
المملكه رائده فيها الان وهي الان اصبحت
محطه انظار العالم في الاستفاده من تقنيه
تحلى وكيف استطاعت انها تخفض المخاطر
واصبح حتى الدول الان اللي عندها
انهار ومصادر اخرى طبيعيه اصبحت تحتاج الى
تحديد المياه
في في الشرق الاوسط صحيفه الشرق الاوسط
نشر التقرير
في 2019
يقول كشف تقريبا بنك الدولي صدر عام 2017
انه بحلول عام 2050 يتوقع ارتفاع مستويات
ملوحه المياه في منطقه الخليج والبحر
المتوسط والبحر الاحمر بشكل ملحوظ نتيجه
الى محطات التحليه في منطقه الخليج اللي
قد تسبب ارتفاع ملوحه المياه بنسبه 20%
موضوع
الاثر التحليه على ملوحه المياه وعلى
البيئه دائما يطرح وفي نفي من جانبنا ودنا
نسمع القول الفصل هل التحليه تضر بيئه
المياه البحريه
ما في مشروع يقام
على سواء الخليج العربي لا يتم دراسه
الاثر البيئي
والاثر البيئي ما هو فقط على الملوحه على
حتى الحياه البحريه واثرها
ويتم الموافقه عليها او منعه فهي موازنه
مصالح
مختلف لكن
البنك الدولي
يشير الى كلام يمكنه اغلبه عام لكن حقيقه
حنا لنا في المملكه الاعلام فوق 35 اربعين
سنه
بالملح هذا يشترون فيه الملح مانع هو الان
الماء
يستخرج منه الماء الحلو ويرجع الماء
المركز او المركز الملحي يرجع مره ثانيه
ويتم دوره البحر تشيل الملح معاه وتطلع
مره مره ثانيه ففي
مستمر وانت قبل لا توافق تسوي دراسه
سرعه الخلط اللي يتم بعد رجوع المياه
المالحه ورجوعها مره ثانيه للبحر
وهذا يعني الى الان يعني حتى دراسي ما في
اي اثار ملموسه بسبب
في تقرير الدكتور محمد حامد الغامدي عديده
على موضوع المياه باخذ يعني ثلاثه منها
واحد يقول ان خفض استهلاك الفرد السعودي
الى النصف من 300 الى 150 لتر في اليوم
سيغني عن جميع ما تنتجه محطات التحليه بكل
تكاليفها الباهظه
فش رايك في في هذه الفكره وهذا مستهدف
الوزاره في الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للمياه
مستهدفه انه الخفض وانشات هيئه جهاز خاص
في الترشيد هذا من المستهدفاته هل فعلا
متوسط الاستهلاك عندنا اعلى من المتوسط
العالمي
الاستهلاك عندنا عالي يعني مقارنه في دول
اخرى نعم عند الاستهلاك اعلى
في استهلاك مباشر وفي استهلاك او نوع من
الشبكه نعم وهذا مشكله المواطن ولذلك حتى
الان الوزاره تعمل على شركه المياه تعمل
على التصحيح الموضوع لكن الفقد
موجود في العالم كله يعني انا كنت في
الجبيل والان في الرياض وفي نسبه فاقد
تتراوح من سبعه الى عشرين الى ثلاثين
الفاقد موجود 30% يفقد نعم فاقد موجود لكن
في عمل
لتخفيض هذا الفاقد
هو جزء من من النظام
نفس الشيء دكتور محمد الغامدي يقول ان لم
يتوقف تصدير المنتجات زراعيه بكل اشكاله
فهذا يعني فهذا يعني اننا نضحك على انفسنا
وعلى الاجيال القادمه نحلي ماء البحر
بتكلفه باهظه ونستنزف مياهنا الجوفيه
ونصدرها على شكل ثمار الخارج مثل التمر
وغيرها اي عقل يقبل ذلك في ظل ندره المياه
وش رايك في في تصدير المنتجات الزراعيه
اللي تستهلك مياه
والله يعتمد على نوع يعني انت تستخدمه
غير متجدده فهي قيم مضافات تدرس يعني ما
اعتقد القطاع ما يسمح بزراعه شمال لا
دراسه جميع الاتجاهات سواء اثره على الماء
ولذلك كنت تلاحظ القرار
زراعه الاعلاف واللي كان في فتره هو
السائد هو اعتقد 80% من استهلاك المياه
الجوفيه في السعوديه بسبب الاعلاف الان
ايضا النظام نظام المياه انه ما في بير
اللي عليه عداد وعليه مقياس هذا ايضا
للترشيد والتوجه دوله واضح والوزاره واضح
في تقنين
[موسيقى]
استخدام المياه جميع انواع المياه ايضا
دعامه لتطوير للمياه
الاستفاده من المياه جميع انواع المياه
هذا يصب في وين تستخدم الماهل وفي الزراعه
لو في الشرب هل في التجاره
هذا سؤال جميل بما انكم انتم تطرحون
مناقصات الشراء المياه هذا يقول لو يمكن
يشرح لنا العلاقه مع الشركات الخارجيه هل
هناك مخاطر من كونها هذه الشركه الخارجيه
تملك محطه انتاج وشاتر هذا على امننا
المائي
لا يوجد اثر الحقيقه لان الاتفاقيات واضحه
هو يملك هذه الاصول
لكن بالاتفاقيات ماله
لو قرر انه ما راح انتج طبعا هو طبعا هو
هنا
شركه المشروع اللي هي فيها التحالف
اخذ التمويل من راس المال للمشاركين في
التحالف وايضا من الممولين فاذا هاي شركه
المشروع لاي سبب من الاسباب عندها خلل
الممول يدخل في في في
اداره المحطه مباشره والدوله الحق ان ايضا
وتاخذ المحطه فالاصل هذا الاصل ما هو
مملوك بشكل مطلق انما النموذج بالكامل هو
نقل مخاطر الطلب عن عن شركه الشركه
المنشاه او اللي هي او التحالف وايضا
مخاطر الانشاء والتشغيل نقلت الى المستثمر
او التحالف
هذا يسال هل هناك ازمه مياه
ليش ليش حدد 2024 وعشرين تحديدا ما اعرف
لكن انا اشوف انه احنا في وضع افضل كثير
من السابق يعني من ناحيه توفرت المياه
ومصادر المياه كيف تقيس هذا الوضع
يعني افضل الان عدد المحطات الانتاج اللي
موجوده سواء تنشا عن طريق قطاع الخاص او
في احلال من قبل مؤسسه العامه اكثر بكثير
من السابق يعني وحنا في 2017 كنا في منطقه
المنطقه الغربيه نتاثر بخروج اي محطه من
كمصدر انتاج الان الحمد لله الوضع اكثر
استقرارا من السابق وايضا الان يدخل محطات
الان في الخدمه ايضا نسبه الاستخدام لبعض
المحطات
في في بافر باقي نستفيد منه يعني
احتياطيه
ورشد المنظومه يعني اليوم المنظومه فيها
نوع من التكامل بقياده الوزاره
تخلي كفاءه المنظومه بالكامل افضل بكثير
من السابع
نفس موضوع ازمه المياه وكذا في كلام دائما
يتكرم يتكرر على انه
الزمن القادم هو الحرب العالميه هي التحدي
الاكبر هو موضوع المياه الى اي مدى هذا
يمثل تهديد اليوم على مستوى العالم هل هي
فعلا بالوصف اللي يوصفونا ولا في
المبالغات انا اعتقد هم يتكلمون عن المياه
الطبيعيه اللي هي
الانهار وجود الانهار في مصبات معينه
ومصادر معينه الان التقنيه
والاستفاده ان تعرف المياه البحار هي
الغالب على الكره الارضيه
نسبه عاليه جدا مقارنه بالمياه الحلوه
تقنيه تحليه المياه شبه حلت الازمه
والتفكير انه ما انه ما في انهار ما في
امطار ففيه ازمه عالميه
التحليه الان وكل خزن
الخزن المدن الخزنه الاستراتيجي هذا حل
وخفض من هذا المخاطب بشكل كبير جدا ابو
عبد الله بالحديث عن موضوع الخزنه
الاستراتيجي انا قرات في في استراتيجيه
المياه رقم صراحه ما هو مطمن يعني شفت
المتوسط الايام
اللي يغطيها الخزنه الاستراتيجي في العالم
هو سبع ايام او او الممارسات المطلوب افضل
الممارسات بينما في السعوديه هو متوسط نص
يوم فقط اللي يغطيه الخزنه استراتيجي
وهذا اظن من ملفاتكم
طبعا زي ما تفضلت كمتوسط على على المملكه
لكن في بعض التجمعات السكانيه الاكثر يكون
عندها يوم يومين ثلاث ايام احنا هذا الملف
طارحين في مشاريع
تصل ان شاء الله الى ثلاث ايام في عشرين
والمتوقع ان شاء الله الى
احنا الان طارحين في السوق ثلاث مشاريع
الجعرانه مليونين ونص
والمنطقه الشرقيه الاحسن منطقه الشرقيه
حدود 4 مليون
للقطاع الخاص
لو بختم ابو عبد الله واقول لك انت انت في
قطاع المياه صار لك اكثر من 25 سنه
عشت كل هذه الرحله من
التحول والتغيير والتطور لو بطلب منك تقول
لي وش اهم اجراء او قرار او او
حدث في الفتره الماضيه
ايجابي لصالح القطاع وش بتختار
انا اعتقد الموافقه على استراتيجيه
الوطنيه للمياه
هذا اهم حدث بانه حدد بوضوح درس الفجوه
ودرس
وزع المنظومه بشكل
جيد وخلى الموضوع لها هدف واضح في
الاستراتيجيه انا اعتقد هذا هو افضل هدف
عالي واعتقد حنا في هالمسار هل نقدر نعطي
الايمان اللي ما اطلع على استراتيجيه او
ما يعرف عنها هلق نعطيهم كذا لمحه سريعه
على اهم اهدافها
الاستراتيجيه درست الوضع
والفجوات سواء هيكليه او او تشغيليا واعطت
مقترحات
للتطوير بما فيها توزيع بين المنتج
والناقل والموزع وافضل الممارسات اللي
اللي تساعد على النقل ايضا مشاكل التمويل
ان احيانا تكون التمويل يكون احيانا هو
جزء من
المصادر المهمه في بعض الاماكن فاعطت ايضا
حلول وفرص بما فيها مشاركه القطاع الخاص
واليات المعرفه ونقل المعرفه
فالاستراتيجيه درست كامل
المنظومه بالكامل وقسمت
سلسله الامداد من البدايه للنهايه واعطت
كل واحد دوره بشكل انا اعتقد انه
جيد جدا ولذلك احنا اليوم في قطاع المياه
عموما دائما في اتجاه تصاعدي
مقارنه بالسابق والجميل انها ملف كامل 124
صفحه تقريبا موجوده في موقع الوزاره
ومنشوره فالمهتم يقدر يرجع لها شاكلك ابو
عبد الله قبول الدعوه
وبالتوفيق في الحفاظ على امننا المائي
وامداداتنا لان الماء سر الحياه شكرا لك
ابو عبد الله شكرا لكم شكرا في اعداد
وانتاج الحلقه ياسر الغانم ومحمد باسعيد
خلف الكاميرات وفي التحرير انس الخليل وفي
الهندسه الصوتيه محمد الحسن وفي الاشراف
على الانتاج رزان هيثم هذا بودكاست تقراط
احد المنتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزع
[موسيقى]